station une lourde pas judiciaire
maintenant à commencer par l' affaire du
sang contaminé
la cour de cassation a prononcé
aujourd'hui un non lieu général dans le
volet non ministériel s'est donc
terminée pour cette affaire un terme
définitif une décision que les familles
des victimes ont beaucoup de mal à
accepter elles ont crié leur indignation
au palais de justice aujourd'hui clément
weill raynal nathalie berthier
depuis plus de 15 ans il espérait ce
troisième procès du sang contaminé
mais en quelques minutes la cour de
cassation a ruiné leurs espoirs
le dossier du sang contaminé est
définitivement refermé la justice
française elle est pourrie tous des
vendus d acheter mon slip
aujourd'hui
la cour en prenant
c'est à rennes
lons dans l'oubli toutes les victimes
ça n'est pas très amusant mais pour les
plus hauts magistrats français
seule la loi compte la cour de cassation
a estimé que les conseillers
ministériels et les médecins parmi
lesquels françois gros claude weil
solberg ou encore jean weber l'un des
anciens patrons de l'institut pasteur
tous impliqués dans la tragédie du sang
contaminé n'avait commis aucune faute
compte tenu des incertitudes
scientifiques de l'époque et de
l'absence de lien de causalité entre les
décisions prises au milieu des années 80
et la contamination des hémophiles et
des transfusés c'est la fin d'un
calvaire la fin d'un calvaire dessous
tous ces mises en examen qui pendant
près de vingt ans se sont fait accuser
du pire crime des crimes de de
complicité d'empoisonnement c'est à dire
le crime le plus horrible alors que la
plupart d'entre tous avaient consacré
leur vie à leur dévouement à la science
et à
la guérison des malades après dix années
d'instruction l'arrêt de la cour de
cassation constitue en tout cas un
désaveu très sévère pour le juge marie
odile bertella geoffroy qui avait été à
l'origine des poursuites contre les 30
prévenu la cour de cassation a donc dit
le droit tout en rappelant que la
justice elle même a ses limites et
qu'elle n'est pas toujours en mesure
d'apporter notamment aux victimes une
réponse qui les satisfasse en rendant sa
décision la cour de cassation a donc mis
un point final à la sphère du sang
contaminé qui restera dans les mémoires
comme l'un des plus grands drames de la
santé publique du 20e siècle